counting the ballots one by one in
georgia
one of several states that could yet
determine who will be the u.s
president on january 20th 2021
the incumbent donald trump demanded
again on thursday
that the counting is illegal and must be
stopped
if you count the legal votes i
easily win if you count the illegal
votes
they can try to steal
the election from us if you count the
votes that came in late
we're looking at them very strongly but
a lot of votes came in leg
trump has repeatedly and incorrectly
said the process could be sabotaged
but it's actually common for states to
need several days to count every
vote but trump isn't just complaining
he's
suing in nevada the trump campaign is
hoping
this woman's story of alleged voter
fraud will
shut down the count there i went to vote
and was told i already voted
i pursued the matter and in years past i
always voted in person
this time they mailed out the ballot and
somebody
took my ballot officials denied stokey's
charges
saying they did everything possible to
help her vote
and in michigan a judge rejected trump's
request
to halt vote counting in that state
around the clock
trump supporters have been protesting
the vote counts
even demanding to be led into the rooms
where the ballots are being counted
after meeting with his campaign staff in
delaware democratic candidate joe biden
said
he trusts the process senator and i we
continue to feel
very good about where things stand
we have no doubt that when the count is
finished senator harris and i will be
declared the winners
so i ask everyone to stay calm all
people to stay calm
the process is working the count is
being completed
and we'll know very soon so
no declaration of victory just yet given
the two
big unknowns the status of the vote
counting
and the status of the trump campaign's
legal challenges
rosalind jordan al jazeera